Dr. Tabak: Arbor Day is a tree planting holiday
celebrated nationwide in our country in 1872
and April 25th is also DNA day when Watson,
Crick, Wilson and Franklin and colleagues
published their findings on the structure
of DNA in 1953.
So today we can combine those celebrations
by planting a clone of the original tree of
Hippocrates and by unveiling for the first
time the gene sequence for the tree.
We are in essence through science returning
the tree of Hippocrates to our campus and
also renewing, reinvigorating, and preserving
the historic living monument for prosperity.
Dr. Lindberg: The tree of course was given
by the ambassador of Greece in '61, planted
in '62 and our institution began business
so to speak in 1962 so the National Library
of Medicine and the tree grew up together.
Dr. Constantine Stratakis: Under this famous
tree in Kos, in the island of Kos where he
mentored practitioners of his art throughout
the known world at the time people of all
religions, backgrounds and ethnicities this
was the NIH of the 5th century.
His Excellency Christos P. Panagopoulos: Hippocrates
used to gather his disciples around him and
the shadow of a plane tree and this tree lives
in this great institution today.
It took American ingenuity and dedication
to clone this in a way as I understand it
and have this dedication again today.
Dr. Lipman: The DNA barcode of life project,
it is a fascinating project for hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of organisms, the goal
is to have a physical specimen from that organism
available in a museum for study and along
with that a short DNA sequence from that organism
and this is very important for conservation
efforts and for basic research.
Dr. Amy Driscoll from the Smithsonian National
Museum of Natural History downtown took a
tiny DNA sample from the original clone that
we had from 50 years ago and had that sequenced
so now we know where the Tree of Hippocrates
is standing in the overall tree of life.
And I think he would've been very excited
about what DNA comparison and other how modern
methods are being used to treat disease.